we have a police force that will
disproportionately imprison good honest
americans and at that point i'm like you
know what screw it abolish the police
yeah i'm i'm i am sympathetic to the
idea of uh in these cities we're just
saying well okay give them give them
what they want if this is what they want
then let them you know you look at san
francisco and all the looting and
everything and i know there are a lot of
people on the right who are saying well
hey that's that's this is what they
voted for so i got no problem with it um
and i understand that but then also i
can't
as fundamentally a law and order
injustice kind of guy i just hate the
idea of bad guys winning and so yeah i
understand that you live in san
francisco you voted for this but at the
same time these are the these are really
bad guys who are doing the looting and
the stealing and i just don't i don't
like the fact that they win and um the
bad guys you get rid of the cops in the
middle of the city and it's going to be
really bad for
whatever good people decide to stay
there but the bad guys will love it i
mean
the cops are acting like bad guys in
many instances a lot of times there's
been a lot of incidences where police
officers don't respond to crimes a lot
of times police officers just stand by
and watch crimes happen because of this
kind of chilling effect which you
correctly pointed out but when it comes
to political issues when it comes to
going after people for not doing the
mask mandate or not locking down when
they were supposed to they're on people
like what on white on rice and they go
after them and they and they go after
them for the fullest extent of the law
and i think there's an argument to make
here that the police forces have been
politicized to a point where only
certain crimes based on your ideology
get punished while others get ignored i
would call that behavior the behavior of
bad guys enforcing bad edicts and
decrees i think it's i think we got i
think there are a lot of good cops a lot
of good cops quit i think when when it
got too hot you had a lot of cops saying
i'm not going to enforce these mandates
and lockdowns i'll resign a lot of who
are saying i will not enforce or be part
of vaccine mandates they resign and
who's left remaining the cops who are
like i don't care tell me what to do and
i'll do it so let me ask you a question
uh do you believe that um like what's
your stance on the second amendment
fully in favor of it yeah do you think
it's like absolute
yeah yeah so uh i i've grown to be you
know fairly absolute on the second
amendment the right to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed it means
what it means it's a verbatim that means
arms period it means during the
revolutionary period there were
privateers privateers had
arsenals in their in these battleships
they had cannons they had grape shot
they could take on governments and they
would the privateers would get a letter
of mark and then go and disrupt french
supply lines these were private citizens
with cannons and so the founding fathers
are like you can have all this stuff all
of it because a militia is a militia
just a bunch of guys with muskets no no
militia has has weapons artillery they
have they have other means
today i think if you want to change
these laws if you want to ban guns well
you got a second amendment to contend
with so the issue now is
in places like chicago in new york where
they don't allow you to even bear arms
in any capacity the cops in my opinion
who would arrest you
simply because you have a gun i don't
care if you're a gang member i don't
care if you're antifa
i don't care if you're a working
working-class plumber you have a right
to keep and bear arms period i don't
care if you're gage gross croits in
kenosha at a riot you have right to keep
and bear arms you don't have a right to
use that weapon illegally to cause
damage to hurt people but you can have a
gun on your purse the second amendment
says it my opinion is very much thanks
to you know credit to michael malus
who's going to be very excited by the
shout out because i'm going to say it
again the police and this we're talking
about this when we're in austin a police
officer who arrests a person who is
constitutionally keeping and bearing a
gun and doing nothing else is a bad guy
and the problem i have now if he's if
he's constitutionally doing so yeah
right but what about what about a uh
a felon
uh uh i well so that's a good argument
felons have gone through due process and
have lost the right to keep and bear
arms that so i would argue that um but i
i've said this before we had alan west
on the show and i said i think you get
out of prison you get your gun back you
get your vote back
but many people correctly pointed out
that the constitution's rights can be
rescinded through due process meaning
you can lose your right to life liberty
the pursuit of happiness if you commit a
crime we lock you up and so you can lose
your right to keep and bear arms if you
commit a serious crime you go through
due process and then we say as a felon
you cannot keep and bear arms
that i i agree with i think there should
probably be some you know a time limit
it's not just indefinite for the rest of
your life it should be like and you're
now a registered felon for three years
and after that we allow you to go back
to having all your rights or whatever
but my issue is in chicago
we have a lot of cases where
35 year old dad he's got two kids
chicago's gang territory he lives on the
south side and he's like i need a gun to
protect my family but the state won't
let him do it so he gets a gun by
driving to indiana buying it legally
going home with it the cops show up at
his house you are going to prison for
the next you know six years for illegal
gun possession which i don't believe
should exist those cops in my opinion
are bad guys they're they're there's
good working class people who just want
to defend themselves and they get
targeted in this way or there's there's
two big stories you have uh in chicago
an old a 60 year old woman from
tennessee
was uh uh i think for or from kentucky
i'm not sure was going to chicago for a
vacation and she brought her you know
snub nose you know 38 or whatever and
when she was at this year's tower now
willis tower they asked before she went
to the observation deck do you have you
know if you have any weapons you would
go to the metal detector she said yeah i
have my my concealed carry with me and
my permit and the cop was like all right
ma'am turn around hands behind your back
you're under arrest and she did go to
prison they actually sent her to prison
and they said we don't care illinois
laws are not you know kentucky's that to
me is evil agreed so i i i don't i don't
think you know at that time you have bad
cops and you had a lot of bad cops
willing to absolutely enforce laws that
are unconstitutional the main issue i
have now is
how many resignations have we seen over
the past year or two there's a video of
a cop in seattle being like you guys win
yelling at protesters i quit i'm out i'm
not doing this anymore they've been
pressured out by the defunded police the
political pressures of the the soros
da's and what's left is you got a video
from seattle where a cop
there's a guy walking backwards with a
baton or a with a bat or something
antifa is pointing things at him and
threatening him and he's walking
backwards with his hands up telling him
to back off
cops are waiting at the intersection and
they yell at him get on the ground hands
on your head then they look over walk
over to antifung i'm so sorry about that
would you would you mind having your dog
step back i don't want anyone getting
hurt thank you so much ma'am and they
arrest the guy the guy who was
retreating from antifa is the guy who
got arrested that's the problem i have
right now if cops are are scared of
black lives matter and antifa that means
it's going to be independents
conservatives libertarians who are going
to be shuffled into prisons and they're
going to be releasing antifa or refusing
to prosecute
yeah i think
first of all the whole following orders
excuses never that that that never
washes and we know that historically and
that goes for cops too and i would agree
that uh you know
finding someone who's
made some basic basically that's like a
paperwork mistake or someone held the
gun legally and they crossed state lines
and then you just decide okay i'm going
to ruin your life i'm just just just
because i can't i'm going to ruin your
whole life uh yeah that that is that is
definitely evil and i do agree also that
there's a problem when we are actively
pushing the good ones out through all
the things that you point out
but i still think that you look at the
cops
who are who are still on the force um
there are still plenty of good ones left
and i've like said i've talked to them
myself
and the reasons that they give why
they're still there one reason is
actually i believe in this job and i
care about it um another reason is a
real simple one with this is what i've
done my whole life this is how i feed my
family
and uh this is how i support my family
and i'm i'm always i'm always
sympathetic to that because i have four
kids myself i haven't been in a position
where i've had to think about am i just
going to leave all this behind and i
want a way to feed my kids i haven't had
to think about that but um
when you really have to think about it
it's it's just
i can certainly understand someone
deciding i'm staying in this because uh
it's this is my livelihood i do agree i
do agree and i don't think um i think
many of the cops that are enforcing this
stuff are mindless in that they don't
know they don't care but i think that
means the good cops that remain and
those who say look i know that's bad but
i have to support my family
they need to start enacting police
nullification like jury nullification
the officers should refuse to enforce
laws and many are that are
unconstitutional or unjust so we have
sanctuary counties sanctuary states for
gun rights where the police have
straight up said we are not going to
arrest anybody for for guns because they
have a right to keep and bear them now i
think it's reasonable if i've got some
kind of long gun or a handgun on my
person i think if a cop comes up to me
and says
you know we want to check out the weapon
to make sure you know it's safe and we
want to talk to you about it within
reason i think that's acceptable but i
also think then if you're if i was in an
area
where
say your
open carry is not allowed or a person
was let's say a person i believe the
police should probably be like hey we
want to talk to you about the weapon we
want you to know that's the statute here
is that you can't have the weapon out in
public but we're not going to enforce
that because it's unconstitutional we
want to make sure you're not committing
any crimes we want to make sure
everything's safe you're good have a
nice day sir
i think the police should be doing that
but and they already do uh they do it in
favor of blm they do it in favor of
antifa and we have to call it out for
what they're doing
and that line i have to disagree with
you a little bit here matt that line i'm
just doing my job i'm just doing this
just for my kids just for my family this
is this is what led to the worst human
atrocities all throughout recorded human
history i'm not just talking about
germany i think that's overplayed over
used but when we look at you know for
for soviet russia as an example with the
kgb even if we look at what's happening
right now in australia people are being
hauled off into camps because they were
around people that tested positive for
covet and police officers are literally
ruining people's lives telling them that
they can't go to the supermarket denying
them basic human rights to food and
water all because they didn't comply
with the whims of the state and the
state is only willing to pull it off
because officers saying well i'm just
doing my job i just have to feed my
family i think it's dangerous and i
think that needs to be called out yeah
just to clarify on that point uh yeah i
don't accept that excuse for police
officers who are doing something evil
like we talked about that that's not
that's i agree with you there that that
is that goes into the i'm following
orders i'm feeding my family if you're
doing something evil you're doing
something evil there's no excuse for it
i'm talking about in general we look
across the country the police officers
who in spite of all of this are still on
the force why are they there i think uh
the good ones anyway i think that's when
you get into two reasons one is i really
believe in this and i want to do it and
the other is i'm feeding my family um
and so it's not just that the only cops
who remain across the board are you know
the bad ones i don't think that's true
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time